i have some exciting news is everybody
ready
um okay so women's wear daily
just announced a brand new lifestyle
magazine that will hit shelves
on june 14th and guess
what it's called
that's it it's just true that's it
and um listen i
this has been my dream honestly since i
was a pre-teenager
ripping out tear sheets um from every
magazine
imaginable to create my very own
wallpaper of imagery look that's me
at 12 years old why i'm holding barbells
i don't know
but if you take a look at the wall
behind me my
floor to ceiling wall to wall
was nothing but tear sheets magazines
have just been really important to me
and our magazine will cover some of the
things we talk about here on the show
and more beauty food travel inspiring
stories and people
and of course news and i hope this
little collection
of pages brings you joy and provides
some escape from everyday life
maybe a little how to get into everyday
life at the same time
and help us see beauty everywhere
that we look and the first issue will
drop
nationally in newsstands that's right
baby
this is all paper
there'll be a digital landing page if
you want to look it's a few images it'll
give you a little
whiff of what we're doing but i'm
kicking it old school
because magazines have been one of the
greatest influences
in my life and the fact that i can look
back on my 12 year old self
and tell her that she's the founder of a
new magazine
is such a good feeling
and it's just very full circle and
i'm so excited i can't wait to share it
with you everything i do
is about putting it out there we have to
create it but it's not for us it's to
put out
you